thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and a censor Boris
Johnson strips the honor from Britain's
honor System with a pack list of gongs
for cronies and even a Knighthood for
his father is it time to abolish the
Prime Minister resignation list
Tick Tock faces bands blocks and probes
across the world as fears grow in
Britain the Chinese spy cameras are
trained on our government and perhaps
even our King as it's under wise up to
the rising threat of China we'll debate
that
plus comedians face protests boycotts
even physical attacks for jokes about
controversial social issues can comedy
survive cancel culture or talk live to a
comedian who somehow has more Twitter
followers than me
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening just before we get
going here is what is called well
Tottenham Hotspur fans won't know what
this is It's called a trophy uh and this
is from the last night's Oscars of
British sports journalism the uh Sports
journalism Awards uh the Park Plaza
Hotel in Westminster and Piers Morgan
has censored won the coveted scoop of
the Year award for our Ronaldo interview
and I just broke the news to Cristiano
who of course has won more trophies than
any other human being alive and he's
very happy for all of us and sends his
best to all the teams so congratulations
to the piers Morganite censor team the
first of many trophies and hopefully
this all goes well for my own football
team who are now 12 games away from the
Premier League title that's going to
stay here all show anyway
let's go up the top please because I
I've lost my threat good evening
from London and welcome to the
award-winning pause peaceful because I
said God I wanted to say that for so
long the honor System is a peculiar
Quirk of British history and for the
most part it's one we can be proud of we
doll out brilliantly British titles like
commander of the Empire to people who've
LED Charities build businesses and told
in their communities for decades we
honor the finest athletes and lavish the
artists and musicians who've blazed a
trail in culture we give an
unforgettable red carpet moment with the
Monarch to our hard-working British
Heroes at least that's the idea but
there's a major quirk in The Quirk and
it's a rotten One Prime Ministers get to
hand out honors and peerages when they
resign even if they resign in
ignominious shame it's supposed to be a
way of thanking a choice for you public
servants who've dedicated their lives to
good government instead has become a
grubby exercise in backstabbing for
cronies David Cameron was rightly
lambastic for packing his resignation
list with 62 Pals after the failed
remain campaign ended his career and not
to be outdone on entitlement and
impunity Boris Johnson is planning a
staggering 100 honors including
reportedly a Knighthood for his own
father Stanley well labor sakir stammer
is rightly sick in the booting
it it's it it's classic uh of a man who
um like Johnson I mean I think the
public would just think this is
absolutely outrageous but the idea of a
an ex-prime Minister promote you know
bestowing on was on his dad for services
to what
well Stanley Johnson's many things he's
a friend of this show
um but I'd like commander of the Empire
should not be one of them if it's his
own son who's recommending it should it
I mean is that right
is daughter Rachel or is his brother
explained that her brother's latest Act
of brazen self-service was this
maybe he thought my dad's 80
one
he has never been acknowledged his
service to the party and to the
environment has never been acknowledged
this is the one thing I can do for him
and I'm Jolly well gonna go and do it
and I don't care what people say right
my father is also around that age and
he's never received a Knighthood for
services to his vegetable patch amongst
other things uh that's not how this
works you don't just give your dad a
night because he's your dad and because
he's got to 80. is that how this system
works now but that's the problem with
Boris Johnson he doesn't just care what
people think at all if Vladimir Putin or
Kim Jong-un pulled a stunt like this
we'd all how would laughter at the scale
of his comedic corruption it Beggars
belief that is happening here if you
resign in shame and disgrace as Boris
Johnson did for lying
and after you've been
will fined by the police for breaking
one of your own laws in a Health crisis
you shouldn't be allowed to then dish
out honors to a hundred of your mates
and relatives
Liz trouser was outlasted by lettuce and
created our economy shouldn't even think
about not Milling anybody either
there'll be no one on left hand or on a
system it's abused by leaders who failed
us and it's a slap in the teeth for the
many people who deserve recognition
should reject this list and scrap
resignation honors before this source of
national pride becomes what is rapidly
becoming and that's a National Disgrace
Telegraph columnist Madeleine Grant talk
TV contributor Paula Roan Adrian and by
talk TV's political editor down in
Westminster Kate McCann uh well I'll
start with UK are you in Westminster or
are you in Downing Street it's so dark
and mysterious
I'm in Downing Street Downey Street in
Westminster in fact uh it's a double
rainbow welcome to the award-winning
Piers Morgan uncensored uh
congratulations for your role in our
scoop of the year I'm not sure what it
was but I'm sure you'll find one as
everyone clambers onto the the glory
Trail
um let's talk about two things I want to
start uh first of all with this honors
Scandal which is what it's becoming
because I don't think for the life of me
think
there should be a system where Prime
Ministers who have to resign in disgrace
should then be able to issue honors to
cronies and in this case apparently even
to his own dad
yeah and look I think there are a lot of
people who will Who will share that
sentiment and one of the things that
Rachel Johnson Boris Johnson's sister
said there which I think Rings true is
that actually her brother doesn't really
care about the reaction that people are
having in Westminster to the nomination
of his dad despite the fact that some
people are saying you know it's not just
the fact that Stanley Johnson is Boris
Johnson's father that there are
questions over what exactly he has been
nominated for but there are some fairly
personal reasons why maybe he might not
be the type of person to be named on an
honors list some allegations of domestic
abuse for example an inappropriate
behavior you know on the front page of
national newspapers too I think what
this says really is that Boris Johnson
is determined to do something for those
who surrounded him while he was in
number 10 and he doesn't really care
that much about the reaction to it he's
nominated around 100 people his
predecessors usually nominate around 60
so it's a bumper list anyway and I think
it's fair to say that this decision has
actually just pushed him further out of
some people's minds in Westminster as a
viable conservative leader of the future
I know beers you might think I can't
believe we're even talking about that
but people do talk about a Boris Johnson
come back I think after his perceived
misstep on the Northern Ireland protocol
deal that we should see next struck and
now this it just makes it more difficult
for people to see that happening right
so Madeline look you're a cons you
identify as a conservative do you yeah I
would say so can you identify as a woman
be a small C rather than a big city yes
okay we have to check these days and
you're a conservative woman
can you we asked 54 people today like we
counted 54 people who we would normally
use on the show to defend the
indefensible when it comes to Boris
Johnson the kind of list we have on a
file can you defend the indefensible
when it comes to Boris and 54 people's
names come up and they normally say yes
not one of them would come on to defend
this to defend him giving his own father
and I'd nothing against Stanley I like
Stanley personally always got on very
well he's been on the show a few times
but for Boris Johnson to be hounded out
of office in disgrace and now dish out a
Knighthood to people including his
father seems to be absurd it's
fabulously tone deaf isn't it yeah and
it's it's sort of you know of course
it's going to
um renew people's doubts about the very
office and the Very honor System as it
currently stands I mean as with so many
things in this country it relies on a
host of Unwritten rules and conventions
that people are expected to honor in in
not just letter but the spirit of these
rules and it's so typical of someone
like Boris Johnson that he would attempt
to overstep the mark to the absolute
maximum degree you know it's like it's
not quite nominating his horse as
consoles it's not far off not far off
and uh you know perhaps the times
cartoon yesterday is right Dylan the dog
is next on the list I wouldn't be
surprised at all
um Paula I speak to somebody who has
obviously turned down a Knighthood and
if you believe that you'll believe
anything
um I remain honorless at the moment but
there's still time I always believe
everything you say appears exactly and
also I don't I actually don't think
working journalists like myself one
should ever accept honors anyway because
it means that you greased upon with a
government a little too closely in my in
my experience but what do you want me
can you
no one will defend it but I'm more
interested about the whole system of
allowing outgoing Prime Ministers what
if it is trust after the 44 days of
total Mayhem in which he created the
economy great of the bound basically
brought us to our financial needs what
if she wants to suddenly start rewarding
people with her own resignation honors
list the problem is what Boris Johnson
has done
to himself and to the conservative party
some may say is dragged our eyes down to
the equivalent of the lower part of the
human body we are watching the diseased
sphincter aren't we you want to get down
below belt with Boris Johnson we don't
know where he's been that staff that we
don't tolerate ordinarily but Boris
Johnson is expecting us to just say okay
too and Rishi sunak is expected to sign
off on that yeah and Richie sunac said
to us that his government is going to be
one about professionalism one about
integrity but whilst our eyes are down
so low on this human body whilst we are
wallowing in the cesspit that has been
created by this lower part of the body
that is what Boris Johnson has done to
be honestly I'm really struggling with
some of your analogies here because the
whole idea of thinking about Boris
Johnson anywhere in the lower abdominal
region is causing me to feel quite
nauseous well some people may used the a
word to describe I don't want to go
there are you feeling a bit feisty after
your holiday but no
um there's kind of another another issue
here okay McCann come back to you at
dining Street
um big big speech tonight by Rishi Suna
really owning this issue of the small
boats one of his five pledges but he was
there on his own Home Secretary who's
come up with this plan sitting in front
of him along with the media but let's
take a look at what British Zoo next
said
that if you come here illegally you
can't claim Asylum you can't benefit
from our modern slavery protections you
can't make spurious human rights claims
and you can't stay
and once you are removed you will be
banned as you are in America and
Australia from ever re-entering our
country now I understand there will be
debate about the toughness of these
measures
all I can say is
we have tried it every other way and it
has not worked
you know I watched it all uh Kate uh
with great interest I mean once again
I'm going to say this I I do find it
quite comforting we have a prime
minister who can string a sentence
together it doesn't sound like a
blithering idiot
um and he made a passionate and pretty
eloquent argument really for nothing
else has worked
let's try this the the problem it seems
to me is I'm not convinced it will work
either what's the general consensus
about it
I think that's right Piers look there
are two questions here one of them is a
legal issue and one of them is a
practicality question on the first one
Sue Ella bravman who as you said was in
the front row of that press conference
watching the Prime Minister give that
speech she's written on the front of
this bill to say look I can't guarantee
that what we're trying to do will meet
the terms of the European convention on
human rights now that's a huge problem
that's basically the Home Secretary
admitting that this is probably going to
get dragged through the courts and we
know what that means because we're
seeing it play out with the Rwanda
policy which by the way is a key part of
this new pledge it requires the Rwanda
policy to make it work so that's the
first issue how does it work legally I
think there are lots of MPS tonight who
would like to see this work in practice
but who still have big legal doubts and
I asked the Prime Minister well look if
it does get gummed up in the courts
would you be prepared to leave the echr
that's what some Tories want what
reportedly the Home Secretary wants and
he said no no we won't need to do that I
think we can get this through so we need
to see whether that's possible the
second issue is the practicality of this
because what the government is proposing
is that if you arrive here in the UK
illegally on a boat you will be detained
you will be processed quickly now
they're saying days and then you will
either be removed to a safe country or
you will be accepted into the UK in some
exceptional circumstances now the
government can't give me numbers for how
many people would be accepted nor can
they give me numbers for how many people
would come here via those safe routes
but what I think is really problematic
is that if you think about the numbers
peers 45 000 people came to the UK last
year if anything near that scale
continued to come the government would
have a real problem trying to process
that number of people within days it
would take weeks months maybe even years
and we don't have the capacity to detain
that many people in detention centers
which by the way haven't yet been built
also we're saying that this legislation
won't apply to the people who are
already here it applies if you make that
Journey from today it is retrospective
but it's not going to apply to anybody
who's already made that Journey so we
still have the issue of People In hotels
around the country that the government
hasn't yet solved yeah so a bit of a
mess all right well Madeleine sell it to
me do you believe in this can it work
well I I've yet to see evidence that
this policy has kind of teeth that
previous efforts to do precisely this
don't have I've yet to see how it would
not be subject to being completely
gummed up in the courts as Kate says
where other policies have failed however
I do wonder if um you know wait for the
experts to properly decode this but I do
wonder if there might be something more
substantive here because if if it is
just as toothless as previous attempts
then the Prime Minister has created the
most tremendous rod for his own back
here you might end up with something a
policy that is seen very publicly to
fail right before the next general
election right so it's quite a Gamble
and I I suspect that he would not have
um spoken in such a sort of strongly
worded positive way about this policy if
he didn't think that he had a reasonable
chance of actually I mean when I
interviewed him last month in Downing
Street he was in fatty that by the end
of this year he would have significant
certainly reduce the number of people
coming over on these boats and he wanted
me to go back and interview him again
end of the year and Mark his card so I
mean Paula he is you know today he was
there center stage on his own Zoella
Bravo sitting in front of him not on the
stage with him quite interesting Optics
he's really owning this which makes me
think because he's no fool where she's
sunac that he must think a bit like with
his brexit deal he's got a reasonable
chance of this working
I don't see what other choice he has
than other to the than to believe in
himself because we were told that brexit
would work in terms of immigration it
hasn't done we were told that Rwanda was
going to work in terms and it hasn't
done and now we are told something again
by the same Administration oh okay so we
got it wrong that time and we got it
wrong this time but this time it's gonna
work and unfortunately for me as a voter
the Optics aren't enough anymore well
having said that I mean there's no doubt
Madeleine that I don't see much from the
labor party which makes any sense to me
either I mean I think this has been a
collective mess now for a very long time
and these numbers are getting bigger and
bigger and bigger as the gangs realize
we are weaker and weaker and weaker and
one of the big problems I mean Kate
talked about processing we're just not
processing people so they're all living
at vast expense in quite nice hotels in
many cases that winds everybody up I
think most of the public are basically
like sort this out yeah whatever you
need to do is transparently ridiculous
that we're allowing tens of thousands of
people to just come on shore on these
boats run by criminal gangs you know a
third of them as it turned out from
Albania yeah not a war-torn country
people probably joining gangs already in
the UK in many cases none of this makes
sense to the average British voter well
quite I think you know the the first
responsibility of a government is first
and foremost to defend our borders and
from that everything else Springs and
once you've shown that borders are
porous and we have no real control over
it then I think it leads to Great doubts
about the ability of government to do
just about anything competently and
successfully and you know your point
about Labor I think is is spot on
because you know say what you want about
the Rwanda policy and it hasn't worked
not a single flight has been sent it is
at least an attempt to look at the
incentives and the business yeah but
here's the problem here's the problem
with it the problem with it is it's
supposed to be a disincentive to people
to the to the smuggling gangs the
trafficking gangs to do this but they're
looking at it and see it completely
Frozen up in court and they're laughing
their heads off they say well this is
this isn't deterrent to anybody right I
mean that's the problem the deterrents
aren't working because they're not
working yeah so they don't deter and and
please let's be clear this is not the
fault of my brethren lawyers who are
doing their job we're always blame
lawyers when in doubt you know this is
the fault of a failed government and
it's failed policies and you you talk
about the labor party and what the labor
party has been able to offer and I can
see that you're concern about that I did
hear Stephen kinnick say recently in an
interview that it's about reaching new
agreements and that's what this
government's got to do no matter what we
do here unless we are able to reach
agreement with other countries it's
never going to work right I mean take me
down finally back to you I mean that it
seems to me the big problem with this is
that it's all very well saying we're not
going to accept anybody they're all
going to go back but you've got to make
sure that where you want to send them
back to agrees to take them and that
doesn't seem to have been agreed in
advance so I'm not you know we've got
one deal with Albania but I'm not aware
of any other deals where countries have
agreed to take anybody back
yeah so there's two things here and
that's a really interesting point
because Rishi sunak during that press
conference today made the same point a
number of times talking about returns
agreements and the importance of them he
also said this legislation isn't a
silver bullet and as part of a package
of measures the government is going to
need to introduce he said it wouldn't
happen quickly and the reason he said
that he's going to meet president macron
in France in Paris on Friday now we
expect that this you know the issue of
cross-channel migrants will come up
unlikely to be some big deal unveiled
about a returns agreement but that's
certainly what the prime minister is
hoping for because they believe that
that would also help disincentivize
people and because I think that's the
point what you what you guys were just
discussing now in the studio the
government sees this just as much as a
deterrent as a publicity campaign if you
like as it does as a working policy what
they hope is that the people Smugglers
and those listening to this conversation
will hear the government saying we're
going to apply this retro respectively
so it's going to start straight away
even if you try and push loads of people
through the channel to tomorrow this
will apply to them so don't think you
can get around it and that in doing that
they will make it more difficult for
people to want to make that Journey
effectively saying to people look don't
waste your money these Smugglers are not
going to be able to give you what you
want the Rwanda policy is a key part of
that and the government believes that
actually lawyers have said that it is
legal it does meet the the terms of of
the legal agreements that the government
has signed up to internationally it is
now being it's going through the appeals
process they're going to have to wait to
see how that comes out but the
government did win the first stage of
that battle so I think there is some
optimism that they can get that through
they need to in order to make this new
legislation and the
problems are saying right the problem
for Rishi is the clock is ticking and he
hasn't got much time you know he's got a
cool election uh within 20 months so he
hasn't got much time can we can thank
you very much indeed uh Pat you're
staying with me a little later next
tonight The Tick Tock surveillance
Balloons by cameras is it time to take
the threat from China a little more
seriously debating that next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names
Piers Morgan is live every week with a
host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you we're leading Britain's
conversation oh no with the people's
Channel don't worry every little helps
for God's sake is nothing original
anymore it's finger licking Goods I'm
loving it look let's be honest we don't
have any fancy speechwriters here but we
do and I promise you discuss the issues
that matter to you yes I'm back talk TV
not with Morgan just before him Monday
to Thursday at 7pm join me just do it
well that one too
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to pierce Morganite
censored your award-winning likely show
a couple of sports updates for you one
is it USA powerlifting must let
transgender athletes compete in the
women's division after losing a
discrimination case
think about that so people who were born
male with all the physical power and
strength advantage of their physiology
from being born male will now compete
against women in power lifting
how could that possibly be fair how come
the Discrimination not now be against
women born to female bodies how can it
be the other way around
this is nuts
the other sporting news is that last
night I interviewed Connor Ben the
British boxing hope who failed several
drug tests and he said this to me on
there last night
that you make it what do you mean
um
I don't think I would um I didn't think
I'd I was taking day by day I didn't
think I'd see another day you were
feeling suicide yeah I'd say so yeah
well some people were moved by that
others were not moved by that one of
those was Chris Eubank Jr who Collard
Ben was supposed to fight just before he
or just up in a moment he failed his two
drug tests so today Chris Eubank Jr
who'd watched the interview on this show
tweeted this
I was 99 sure that Connor Ben was a
cheat but after watching that interview
with Piers Morgan now I'm 100 sure
imagine failing two drug tests and then
trying to play the victim the balls on
this kid or should I say the eggs on him
to which Conor Ben responded you're sat
there trying to play the victim but
tried blackmailing me for a million
pounds you bleep
uh so I think one of the things for sure
it's kind of been does get cleared to
box again in the UK and I think that
will depend on whether he ever hands
over the so-called dossier that will
exonerate him which only he has
uh that fight with Chris Eubank JR could
be a little bit tasty as they say in the
trade
China has accused the U.S government of
overacting after it banned federal
employees from using Tick Tock the
social media app has more than a billion
users worldwide critics fear is the
Trojan Horse that's mining masses of
data for the Chinese State well China's
face is still a criticism over spy
balloons it's been using over the U.S
claims that his surveillance cameras are
spying on the UK government and property
and even the Royal Sandringham estate of
our king plus The Sensational claim for
the U.S government sources that covid
most likely originated in a Wuhan
laboratory and not in a wet Market as
first thought is it time many are asked
in the west got wiser to the rising
threat of China where joining me now as
the chair of the UK's defense that
committee Tobias Elwood and geometrical
analyst Cyrus Jansen in the United
States Tobias Elwood let's take Tick
Tock really is a kind of emblem of all
this Tick Tock is a phenomenal success
story there's not a young person and a
few old people
um in the world he's not either familiar
with it or using it a billion users one
in seven on the planet are using this
but China controls Tick-Tock there is a
belief that China's state has a direct
involvement in Tick Tock should we be
more worried than we are about Tick Tock
basically being used by the China state
to Hoover up information it can then use
against us
yes uh absolutely China is taking
advantage of the fact that it doesn't
distinguish between military or civilian
companies it has a law that says that
any company has to share data with the
state it uses Tick Tock as the way to
control its own people and this is
spilling out to be able to watch what
else is going on around the world when I
saw this story break that uh Canada the
United States and indeed the EU were
Banning Tick Tock but Britain had
decided not to go down this route
um I had flashbacks to that debate about
Huawei that you might recall where it
took backbenders the likes of myself Tom
toucan hat and others to get the the
government the UK government to flush
out Huawei this Chinese company from
British telecoms and it's a I think a
sign of the the bigger picture that
we're failing to grasp here of how China
is becoming more assertive more abrasive
and exploiting the limitations if you
like of our International rules-based
order to further its own aggressive
agenda and we need to wake up to where
all this is going we're focused on
Ukraine at the moment and Russia but
worst case scenarios that Russia and
China start working together in this
access to uh redesign if you like our
rules-based order which as I say has
become rather wobbly in the last 30
years okay let's bring in Cyrus Jansen
you don't agree why
I don't agree because what we have to
fundament fundamentally understand is
how Tick Tock is actually two ecosystems
right when we think of Facebook for
example that's one platform but the way
that Tick Tock is structured is that
there's actually two versions you have
one that is located domestically within
China the other one is actually Tick
Tock that is around the world so the one
that is around the world their servers
are not located in mainland China they
have they store their data separately uh
that you know the Chinese government
does not have access to them so it's a
very very clear thing that we need to
understand is that there's two
ecosystems here within mainland China
they use a version called now doin is
the domestic version that the Chinese
government most definitely has control
and access to they'll be definitely
censoring content there but Tick Tock is
a very different animal and most people
don't understand that distinction peers
well you seem very trusting of that
distinction and this the separation of
judge's estate when it comes to take
tell but how can you be so sure I mean I
wouldn't trust the Chinese in this kind
of area of ownership of data
particularly of Western data as far as I
could throw them why are you so trusting
well I think the main reason is is up
until this point there has been no
evidence of actually any harm to any
American or foreign citizen in relations
to National Security you know there's a
huge evidence Gap and that's what we're
seeing is that many of these concerns
are completely overblown
well Tobias you're you're shaking your
head why
well because uh some American
journalists were actually their
locations were found by the Chinese
because of their use of tick tocks I
understand this call to say that there
are two separate ecosystems but can we
trust the Chinese not to sort of equate
the two or take advantage of the fact
that they are uh owning this uh both uh
of the ecosystems in the future and this
is what we need to wake up to is where
is our world going what is China doing
with all this data it's as is important
now as terrain on the battlefield and we
need to recognize that we need to start
to stand up to China China is not
abiding by our International rules and
Norms when they do so absolutely they
should be included in the International
Community but until they do so then
absolutely we should be joining the
United States Canada and the EU for
blocking Tick Tock for the moment you
know when I was in um Shanghai doing a
documentary a few years ago about
Shanghai
uh I'll address this to you Cyrus it was
interesting because the Chinese
government had tried to ban young
Chinese kids teenagers from using social
media and they had 3 000 government
employees mainly based in in Beijing
whose only job it was was to stop the
kids getting onto Twitter and I guess
Tick Tock and all these other things uh
at the time but they were way behind the
kids on this the kids were way ahead of
the government they were leaps out of
them so they're all able to do this so
is it a case of the Chinese would like
to have
more control perhaps than they have but
they can't actually guarantee it because
the kids are out of them
um well first of all I actually I
watched that documentary you did in
Shanghai that was a fantastic Insight
really enjoyed that thank you and I I
think this case is what's interesting is
is that Chinese social media is is so
popular within China and it is it is an
absolutely part of the culture with
young people now I mean I I I'm a
Creator on Chinese social media as well
I've made many videos on there and it's
it's an entire system that is very
intertwined into society right now in
China so you know social media is a part
of every everybody's life in China
including young youth right now I mean
many of them are on the platform and and
do so what's interesting though Piers is
that the Chinese government has
recognized that social media is a very
big problem for all of us right we all
have this social media addiction the
cell phone addiction and they have
started to put in regulations for
example if you're under the age of 18
you know you're going to be regulated to
for example using Monday to Friday
you're going to have access for about 45
minutes a day on that social media
platform so it's different certainly
than we have in you know the UK and
Western Nations where we have unlimited
use but what's interesting is a lot of
parents that I talk to are like wow
that's actually pretty it's pretty good
standard you know that I mean that's
ideally what we want to have happen it's
just different you know Chinese
government is able to you know and put
it I mean to buy someone there is
another way of flipping this coin isn't
it which is use of social media I think
is pretty much out of control in the
west young people are spending
inordinately long periods of time on
this probably to the detriment of their
mental health certainly anxiety levels
of through the roof because of things
like Instagram and the algorithms and so
on you know there is a a different way
to look at this where you say actually a
bit of totalitarian state control of
usage of social media may not
necessarily be a bad thing for a country
I'm surprised to hear you peers uh
promote a totalitarian state answer
solution
exactly what I said what I phrased it
very carefully that when it comes
specifically to the amount of time young
people should be allowed to be exposed
to these things is there an argument
that a totalium regime like a
totalitarian regime like China the way
they've got about this in putting on a
Time control is that a mad idea to say
to actually impose a similar time
control on young people I think young
people spend way too much time on this I
don't have to disagree I don't disagree
with the amount of time people are
spending on social media on screens
indeed in front of TV but I don't
believe the state should be imposing its
rules and I certainly wouldn't be taking
lessons from China that takes full
advantage of in the cover of these rules
to then spy on its own population to
actually control the message and to
destroy any credit criticism to arrest
people who they say something against
the state that's not a direction of
travel I would like to go down the
argument about how much we know we're on
the screens every day absolutely that is
something that culturally we need to
discuss and address because this
essentially is a New Concept did you and
I have these screens when we were
growing up no we didn't so yes we've got
to come to terms with a new Society I
don't believe anybody should be on
social media who's Anonymous I believe
you should actually be able to be
accounted for that way you wouldn't get
all the horrible messaging that no doubt
you get and parliamentarian well yeah
but the trouble is that we I've got to
leave the debate here unfortunately but
the trouble with that argument
unfortunately is you go to a
totalitarian state you go to somewhere
like Iran or China or whatever actually
the anonymity allows people that live
there to post things they want to post
which may be critical of the government
the moment we get arrested get arrested
if they dare to criticize what the
government is doing that obviously is
completely wrong but the one away the
public in these countries can post stuff
publicly is to do so anonymously so that
is the argument against removing
anonymity on social media final words
fairness though appeared yeah in In
fairness though I mean if you're going
to be using Chinese social media you do
have to register your national ID card
right so it actually there is an
advantage into there because it does
reduce the amount of spammers and people
that are you know that are doing this
and the other thing that we need to make
sure that is is heard is that Chinese
citizens they use social media to give
feedback and criticisms to the Chinese
government to help improve the society
very common for for for Chinese
government to make public policy
adjustments based on outrage and
outlashing of people on social media
very common throughout China it's also
very common as is in Russia for people
in government to read those messages and
put the people who post them in prison
uh but we'll discuss that another day
gentlemen um one at a time thank you
both very much and even joining me I
appreciate it coming next a question
being asked on both sides of the
Atlantic it's polarized to Party
politics broken Beyond repair I'll talk
to the former Democratic presidential
hopefully blew up in 2020 and was a
household name around the world at the
time he's now quit the Democrats to
start a new independent movement why and
can it work
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel note
what are you uh every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to Piers organization
Andrew Yang raised tens of millions of
dollars as an upstart Democrat candidate
for U.S president 2020 bolstered by
appearances on podcasts like The Joe
Rogan Experience he even came to support
a billionaire Twitter owner Elon Musk
who set up a time I support Yang adding
our first openly goth president this is
very important I'm sure we could all
agree with that it's a reference to Mr
Yang's teenage musical taste well now
he's quit the Democrats to begin a new
movement claiming two-party politics has
failed he joins me now Andrew Yang thank
you very much indeed for joining Piers
Morgan uncensive
it's great to be here thanks for having
me Pierce so look everyone basically
agrees American politics has gone
slightly Bonkers uh you now appear to be
heading to a situation where an
octogenarian may be shaping up against
someone who would become an optogenarian
if he was to get re-elected in a
presidential race out of 320 million
people this does seem to be at the very
lower end of ambition for a country like
the United States you've gone off now on
your own path how is that going is it
really a place for someone like you in a
movement like you to cut through
America's apparently in transit and
two-party system
well tens of thousands of Americans have
already signed up for the forward party
peers because they know that the
two-party system is crumbling before our
eyes and you're talking about a
potential match-up between Joe Biden and
Donald Trump about 60 of Americans are
not excited about either of those
choices and it's a very clear emblem of
the dysfunction you're talking about
where you have two parties that claim to
represent the majority of the American
people meanwhile about half of Americans
are political Independents and
unrepresented in this system that's what
we're trying to change with the forward
party your critics would say you started
with a bit of a bang but you're not
getting much traction in fact it sort of
appears to be slightly running out of
steam is that true what can you do about
it if you are
well the forward party is growing by
Leaps and Bounds every single day I
travel around the country and millions
of Americans are fed up and they're
figuring out that there's something we
can do about it we can come together
form this new movement the forward party
and create more choices for ourselves in
the half a million elected races uh
locally around the country but also at
Federal races and at every level because
at this point the discontent is so high
now you've been vocal about uh the woke
Brigade I think you shared my view a lot
of it is lunacy but so is someone like
Governor Ron DeSantis for example how do
you find any kind of real traction on
policy or ideology we should take you
away from the conventional politicians
oh if you dig into these issues peers
you see that there's generally a
consensus middle ground and
unfortunately on either side of the
aisle now you're getting more currency
and points for lambasting the other side
than you are in solving the problem it
was a U.S senator who said to me at this
point in the American political system
is a problem is worth more to us
unaddressed politically than it is
addressed and I want you to think about
those implications so even if someone on
one side of the aisle might have the
right approach they're actually going to
be rewarded not for Reaching Across and
trying to compromise and craft a
solution but they'll be rewarded if they
just stay on their side and throw rocks
at the other side but I would say a
little respect for for you and what
you'll you're trying to do here and I
agree with all the points you make but
as you know in politics you can only get
things done if you actually win power
and I would say you've got two hopes of
winning power certainly in terms of
winning a presidency and that's no hope
and Bob Hope so what is the end game
here for you because I you're not going
to win the White House how are you going
to get power are you hoping to do it at
local level and then build up or what
so peers of these 500 000 local
elections around the U.S about 70
percent are are uncontested or
non-competitive in 75 percent of the
country you essentially have one party
rule so an example in California we just
kicked off with the common sense party
of California we're registering new
members every single day because they
want a choice in their state the same is
happening in South Carolina and other
states around the country so we're going
to get hundreds even thousands of
locally elected officials in office over
the next several years and just keep on
heading up from there okay and if it all
works the way you're selling it to I
mean it sounds very exciting as I'd
expect if it works and you end up
becoming president of the United States
you've got 20 seconds how are you going
to fix America
we're going to fix America by bringing
us together on the things Americans can
actually agree on and that is 75 80 of
the problem right now appears if you get
a group of Americans together you're
going to be shocked at how much we can
get done when we get rewarded for
solving problems not just yelling what's
your number one priority
our number one priority right now is to
remind Americans that we're all still
one people and that your fellow
Americans are not your enemy
I rather like that Andrew Yang great to
have you on the program thank you very
much
thanks beers appreciate it good to see
you well next to us comedians face
protest boycotts even physical attacks
and jokes can comedy survive canceled
culture
[Music]
thank you he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
thank you
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no with the people's Channel no what are
you uh every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy
speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the tour the government
says it will stop the boats with tough
new laws and Britain's patience and
illegal migrants has run out hasn't it
peers The Duchess of York says she
hasn't received an invitation to the
coronation as she defends prince Andrew
neither his peers and after being
criticized and canceled the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show is making a comeback
he's not on that either but that's
coming up after Pierce at nine o'clock
foreign
[Music]
I say delighted I've just found
something else which may make that look
ridiculous but let me joined by a very
famous comedian he's an Egyptian uh
comedian called basa Musa who somehow
has 10.9 million toilet photos which is
more than me it's currently on tour in
the UK with a new show it's Ambassador I
was about to congratulate you on having
more followers with me and I went to
look at you on Twitter and discovered I
blocked you yes you blocked and I bumped
you to discuss cancel
why did I block you uh well I was mean
to you what did you say uh well you see
I'm already I I admitted that was me
yeah it was there during the 6th of
January uh resurrection and you were of
course angry and then I was angry and
then I said like said the guy who had
Donald Trump with him on his profile
picture ah and then of course you
blocked me yeah well okay I've unblocked
you yeah
I don't think being blocked on Twitter
is canceling no it's not it's not
because you're still able to do what you
want to do yeah your feet you're free
you shouldn't be forced to listen no
right no the Democracy isn't is a noisy
Place yeah but I don't have to be there
when I don't listen to something do you
two block people not much actually I
prefer
yeah I don't know and I don't care and
they don't know yeah just keep yelling
it's great I want to play a clip this is
Chris Rock so we're we're only a few
days away from the Oscars and it was a
year ago that the slap that went around
the world would see where Chris Rock was
punched by Will Smith for apparently
mocking uh Will Smith's wife Jada this
is what Chris Ross
Chris Rock said in his Netflix special
this week about this
that's right you said it
say the Rope will say they always say uh
words hurt
that's what they say gotta watch what
you say cause words hurt
you know anybody that says words hurt
has never been punched in the face
okay so Madison look you're a comedian
highly successful but you come from
Egypt where you know a lot of censorship
goes on but a suppression goes on uh not
unknown I suspect for comedians to get
you know punished or even put in prison
on occasion well I got my hair my show
canceled a couple of times right and I
had to venture to leave so that that's
for me is cancer but you fled to the
west where you hoped there would be
Liberation and freedom for people like
you and you've come to a place where
comedians are now getting punched and
assaulted not just Chris Rock I think uh
Dave chappella happened to on stage and
others uh often for expressing in
Chappelle's case you know a view about
say the transgender debate which seemed
to be completely reasonable
what does that say about comedy and
where we are and how does comedy come
through this attempt to basically
physically beat it into submission well
first of all people a lot people say can
comedy survive cancer culture my
question is can cancel cultures survive
comedy because comedy will always be
there you cannot cancel comedy you could
be outraged you can punch you can slap
but these are isolated cases if you're
someone sort of attack you uh no no what
would you do if they did would you I
would punch you back because I work out
in the gym
Chris Rock of punched Will Smith back no
I think Chris Rock got his revenge a
year later with a 40 million dollar
check from Netflix yes so that is
something that will last longer uh I
would have loved if Chris Rock had sued
Will Smith because that was not cancer
culture this is assault no but it's
interesting isn't it because I remember
at the time writing a piece almost
defending Will Smith to a bit where I
thought if he genuinely believed Chris
Rock who had history of doing this to
Jada Pinkett Smith Will's wife of
mocking her if he genuinely thought that
Chris Rock at the Oscars in front of a
billion viewers was mocking his wife's
alopecia because she'd lost her hair I
think a lot of men might have stepped in
and given him a slap so it may have
seemed insane but it didn't seem that
insane to me of a husband defending his
wife against what he may have thought
was a very personal attack I don't know
I mean it's the Oscars isn't it it's not
the WWE you can't decide in principal
people you can't go punching people
because I'm not saying is right I'm
saying I could understand he's got two
kids he's got to set an example to his
kids
I'm watching Yellowstone at the moment
the cowboy drama with Kevin Costner
every time there's anything any argument
they punch each other so I mean there's
something quite you know it's a
throwback but I'm not against it if
people buy it badly and as a martial
artist I can understand the need you're
martial artist I am a martial wow I can
understand the need to want to defend
yourself but I think Madeleine is right
you defend yourself in a smart way and
Chris Rock has been Smart in that he's
now got that paycheck but if you allow
people to have a leeway of using
physical Force to stop people where do
you draw the line I agree I think I
think it's when you cross the lines when
performers are performing if you try and
do that it's completely wrong massive
where are we with the woke culture in
comedy because Bill Maher in America
says they've become now a much better
source of joke material than the than
the far right well you know with the
pendulum the pendulum Theory it goes so
far to the right it comes back too far
to the rest now a lot of people make fun
of the War culture and I think if people
please yeah sometimes but I I my comedy
is more about my personal Journey but I
do sometimes in comedy because if when a
group of people feel themselves too
entitled
too isolated too protected that's what
happens this is what happened with Dave
Chappelle I mean like uh why would
transgender people all Muslim people or
gay people or women be immune to satire
well this is a comedian Echo burn a
manner it was a rough Northern comic
very inappropriate about today's status
very offensive but his view was he used
to mock everybody because he couldn't
understand why if he started making
exceptions well where do you stop yeah
there is a kind of Purity to that
argument absolutely because a lot of
people say where do you draw the line
the better question is who will draw the
life yeah and how do you guarantee that
tomorrow that line will not proceed on
your own freedoms well I'm going to draw
the line here bass if you're on tour at
the moment good luck with the tour I'm
so glad I've unblocked you oh thank you
I'm happy that I came back follow me and
tell your followers to follow me and be
I'd be nice
thank you both very much indeed uh well
that's it from me whatever you're up to
keep it award-winning and uncensored
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on